the number 15 story line as the 2019 NFL
season approaches deals with the first
overall pick in the draft Cardinals
quarterback Tyler Murray will he be the
next big thing in the National Football
League
look the Cardinals are betting that he
will be and as I said all along during
the pre-draft process it's better to
guess that he will be the next big thing
and be wrong than to guess that he won't
be and pass on him and let him become
the next big thing in the NFL elsewhere
because if he truly does become the kind
of star that we saw last year from
Chiefs quarterback Patrick mahomes and
Browns quarterback Baker Mayfield that
can transform a franchise that can fill
your stadium that can sell a lot of
jerseys it can get you in primetime and
it can rebuild that national following
that the Cardinals were dangerously
close to forming just a few years ago
when they almost made it to the Super
Bowl in 2015 and they were consistently
in postseason discussion now they're
irrelevant they won't be irrelevant if
calimary does become that next guy that
we're talking about every Monday based
upon what he did on the football field
and he can do it he can run he can throw
the question is does it translate to
this level specifically as it relates to
his size there's a fundamental
difference between him and Russell
Wilson
I met with both of them just a couple of
hours apart prior to the Super Bowl and
there is a real distinction between
Wilson's size and his overall girth his
his overall build then there is with
calimary
Kent calimary deal with the kind of
pounding he's gonna face in the National
Football League can he avoid the hits if
he takes the hits will he be able to
keep going or will he be injured those
are all questions that will help
determine whether or not he does become
the guy that justifies the Cardinals
faith him and even if they're wrong they
were still right in rolling the dice
because if you get one of these guys you
are gonna have a great and interesting
and compelling team for at least a
decade we'll see if Murray becomes that
guy right away in his rookie season
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports